John Key Riku is a former CIA officer he
joins us tonight John thanks very much
for coming on thanks for having you
worked at CAA for a long time under John
Brennan who ultimately backed your
prosecution for which you were sent to
prison for a crime that I don't think
would be considered a crime today
so tell me with that perspective your
reaction to watching John Brennan
trotted out before the cameras daily
almost for the last two years as an
expert on the Russia an expert
conspiracy I think this was scandalous
for a number of reasons the most
important of which is that John Brennan
has repeatedly used the word treason the
word traitor when describing the
president treason is a death penalty
charge is he seriously saying or has he
been saying that the president ought to
be executed for something having to do
with a scandal that really never existed
to me John Brennan just simply is not a
serious person
he shouldn't be taken seriously by us or
by anybody else and I'm gonna get a
little bit personal here too I worked
with John Brennan for many many years I
always thought that he was in over his
head intellectually and I think he's
proven that repeatedly in his responses
and reactions to the news coming out of
this this investigation you said that I
think the default assumption for most
people including me is that the director
of the CIA is a very smart man you the
best in the brightest very complex job
it is I've watched him closely in his
public performances over the past couple
years and have concluded that he's not
very bright I'm not attacking him no no
okay I'm observation but it's clearly
the case how does a guy like that run
the CIA how do you get that job you get
that job by by latching on to George
Tenet before George Tenet even entered
the CIA John Brennan in the 1990s was
George tenets briefer when George was at
the National Security Council as the
director of intelligence programs and so
when George became the deputy director
of the CIA he took John over with him
and then just promoted him through the
ranks until he was practically cabinet
level I mean that's how a just pure game
is well that's all it was and it took
less than a decade he was on a rocket
ride to the top of his career track at
the CIA so now I guess the the results
of all of this stuff that we've watched
for a couple of
is that the ordinary person me everyone
else knows that these agencies are run
by people who are much less impressive
than we thought with political agendas
and in some cases are ruthless and cruel
you're one of the people who felt the
sting of that you went to prison I did
thanks to John Brennan guys like Roger
stone are headed to prison who because
of that where the pardons here I mean is
it time for the executive branch to send
a really clear message we're gonna stop
the destruction of innocent people by
completely out of control bureaucrats I
think it is the time for pardons
I heard Senator Lindsey Graham say
earlier today that pardons probably
would not be met very well right now in
the United States Senate I think he's
wrong I think that the American people
understand that the people have been
wronged
look at Mike Flynn what that poor guy
has gone through look at look at Roger
stone you know these are all processed
felonies Tucker we talked about this
once before these are felonies that
really didn't exist until these people
were thrown in on this investigations
exactly their crimes that would never
have been committed otherwise since the
investigation has come to naught I think
it's time to wipe this little and by the
way it doesn't make sense not to pardon
people I really think this is a scam and
a hoax and the people that's very hard
wait this really illegitimate then you
have an obligation to make it right but
that's all right the people who are
wrong and I hope you're on that list
thank you so much great to see you
tonight think the pleasure is always
mine